non non je disais un autre sujet
concerne le ministère de l'intérieur
c'est celui des gilet jaune
effectivement sujet qui vous tient à
coeur patrick peloux vous avez signé
cette tribune qui est paru hier dans
l'express alors de quoi s'agit-il du
fait j'essaye de résumer que lors des
manifestations du gilet jaune les
blessés qui sont pris en charge à
l'hôpital sont pour certains ou
peut-être la totalité inscrit dans un
fichier fichiers dont on ne sait pas
très bien la finalité mais fichiers que
vous estimez totalement anti
déontologique est contraire au secret
médical
une centaine de vos confrères ont signé
cette tribune vous allez nous expliquer
on écoute tout d'abord un autre de vos
confrères il s'agit de médecins
urgentistes gérald kerzec qui était ce
matin l'invité de sud radio
ça a commencé le 13 avril j'étais gamin
servi ou l'administration m'a demandé de
remplir comme d'habitude un fichier qui
s'appellerait pas le dossier médical on
parle pas du tout de données médicales
ont rempli tous les jours un dossier
médical des données secula de remplir un
fichier parallèle de repérer les malades
gilet jaune dans le cadre des
manifestations et des rentrées dans ce
fichier
vous avez été confrontés aux mêmes wipro
c'est à dire en fête la naissance de ce
fichier et est concomitante
suite de l'attentât du 13 novembre en
fait 13 novembre il ya eu un problème
c'était voilà en 2004 et gilet jaune
vient d'avoir été gilet jaune et on
s'aperçoit qui est un problème dans
toute catastrophe c'est l'identité
vigilance c'est à dire comment on
identifie les gens il y avait eu des
problèmes que l'on peut comprendre de la
part des patients des familles qui
cherchait des malades et on les trouvait
pas donc du coup l'idée avait été de
dire bon ben voilà on va faire un
système informatique des victimes
civique d'accord pour identifier les
victimes et puis pour savoir où elles
vont et c'est bon donc normalement ce
fichier la devait servir à des trucs
c'est très exceptionnel exceptionnelle
et qui est un peu rassemble je dirais le
à la fois la communauté médicale la
communauté de sécurité publique et c est
en fait quand est arrivé ces
manifestations et le début des
manifestations ils ont dégainé ce
système d'information qui est un
véritable fichier en disant voilà il
faut identifier les gilet jaune et on a
été très surpris de voir d'un coup dans
des communications des tas de dire bon
bah voilà il ya eu tant de victimes
il ya eu tant d'urgence absolue tant de
urgences relatives et c'est donc c'est
un véritable fichier à bahreïn était
comique et s'est sorti de la salle luc
hees a été peu voilé à l'intérieur
notamment et ça et ça sert de fichage
alors c'est un véritable problème parce
que nous sommes à l'époque
si vous voulez où on parle du big data
des nouveaux cloud des nouveaux systèmes
informatiques etc et de la naissance de
ces fichiers qui sont en fait on ne sait
pas trop où ça va ça va la direction
générale de la santé c'est la direction
générale de la santé qui est qui les
orchestre mais on sait pas trop où ça va
on sait pas trop qui fait quoi s'en sont
défendus face je crois qu'ils ont dit
non et mais on n'a pas transmis à
l'homme
mais à chaque fois toujours s'en défend
mais c'est un véritable c'est véritable
interpellation laquelle il ya quelle est
la finale et pourquoi pourquoi vouloir
tenir cette comptabilité je vous dise
était initialement j'avais regardé gilet
jaune a donc dans le cas des gels et
jobin jeu à moi à mon avis c'était pour
se dire bon ben voilà il ya eu tant de
victimes n'y a pas de tant de victimes
que ça il n'ya pas tant de répression
que ça ça devait servir de commerce
d'abord d'abord même si l'utilité censés
prouver anvers sais qu'il y beaucoup de
victimes c'est qu'une beaucoup de casse
lisez le mouvement pour wii a priori de
dire qu'il y avait pas de remercier on
peut le voir avec deux côtés on peut le
garder on peut le voir des deux côtés
mais voilà donc ce qui ce qui fait que
d'un coup de gaia une sorte de violation
des ontologies qu c'est ce qu'on a voulu
signaler en disant voilà on a on va vers
des fichiers où on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
vont devenir
alors ça interpelle sur un autre système
qui n'est pas connecté avec celui-là
mais qui s'appelle le système sinus qui
est un système d'information sur pareil
les victimes en cas d'événements etc et
qui est totalement lié au ministère de
l'intérieur et qui sert est vrai pour le
coup celui là est extrêmement compliqué
à gérer mais il faut savoir qu'à partir
du moment où vous avez un accident de
car un accident de circulation ou des
victimes nombreuses ces systèmes
informatiques se sont déclenchés est ce
que la cnil est vraiment informé de
toutes ces informations qui passent
c'est une interpellation
est-ce que ça doit aller c'était dans la
pétition est ce que ça doit aller vers
une mission d'information ou une
commission d enquête parlementaire il a
dû rendre samedi dernier
il devait encore être en glisse parfois
j'ai lu que t3 grâce à un peu plus
samedi dernier n'a pas été n'a pas été
déclenché maintenant il se méfie ça vous
choque c'est lui bien oui assez malgré
tout parce que ce qui est très gênant en
fait déjà c'est l'existence de ce
fichier c'est ensuite tout ce qu'il ya
eu quand le l'existence officielle assez
excitée par patrick pelloux elle pouvait
être l est les combles elle et je trouve
qu'elle s'impose complètement entendent
attentats entendent manifestation c'est
un peu plus complexe mais je pense
surtout qu'une fois encore c'est la
question du contexte qui doit être
proposée c'est à dire que on a eu le
sentiment qu'elle a fois le gouvernement
gérait fort mal cette crise des gilet
jaune mais qu'il était peut-être dans
une logique un petit peu à la 1068
autrement dit on se souvient tous du
moment où finalement le désordre fini
par agacer les français où ils
retournent dans le giron de de gaulle
parce que trop c'est trop et en fait je
pense que le gouvernement mise sur
l'effet chienlit la juste oublié qu'il
n'était pas de gaulle qu'il avait pas ce
respect là et cette confiance là et
qu'aujourd'hui à miser sur l'effet
chienlit on a surtout une impression
d'absence de maîtriser une impression
d'une crise qui n'en finit pas de
s'étirer et qui met à mal aussi ses
capacités et je pense qu'on rentre
encore dans cette logique où les gens
ont l'impression que le gouvernement
veut décrédibiliser un mouvement qui
entre nous n'en a pas besoin parce qu'il
est tellement protéiforme que de toute
façon il ya des éléments tellement fou
que aujourd'hui les choses sont quand
même en train de reprendre de la
distance donc je pense que c'est inutile
c'est bête d'en arriver là et surtout on
est toujours dans la question du
mensonge c'est à dire que l'ap-hp nos
fait une belle sortie en disant c'est
pas vrai c'est faux il n'y a jamais eu
de fichiers pour le lendemain battre en
retraite
c'est pareil pour la pitié salpêtrière
et le mensonge à ce maillot là on va pas
que ça devient un sujet vendeur la
parole biblique dhabi
justement sur l'effet chienlit et la
volonté de décrédibiliser le haut il y
avait quand même plusieurs moments dans
ce long mouvement c'est un mouvement
inédit de par sa de par sa longueur il
ya eu clairement exceptionnel inédit
c'était moi j'ai appelé ça un hostie un
objet social non identifié qui a
commencé mi novembre nous sommes à
quelques à quinze jours d'une dune
élection européenne ni le débouché
électoral ni le débouché grand débat n'a
complètement asséché ce moment parce
qu'il faut le regarder de manière
quantitative même s'il ya de moins en
moins de monde
ce qui me frappe c'est que le soutien
des français reste non négligeable
compter sur le soutien et la sympathie
on est sur 50% ce qui n'est pas
négligeable parce que les français
voient dans ce mouvement
quelque chose qui leur parle qui résonne
la klein la crainte du d la crainte
d'une excusez moi du déclassement le la
crispation sur le pouvoir d'achat etc
moi ce qui m'a frappé ça a été la
dissociation systématique entre les
violences et ce mouvement alors même que
clairement c'est que les gilets jaunes
ont participé à des violences
symboliquement le moment où le soutien à
ce mouvement et le plus fort c'est une
enquête faite au lendemain du 1er
décembre où il s'est passé ce trail du
côté de l'arc de triomphe
maintenant sur la question du fichier ya
il ya un passif français sur la
constitution de fichiers qui doit
résonner qui doit inquiéter le
gouvernement est peut-être moins sur une
logique de pourrissement mais ne sait
pas trop comment gérer cette queue de
comète que constitue le
mouvement est donc dans ce cadre là les
français sont très sévères pourrissement
d'un côté incapacité à résoudre la crise
de l'autre malgré le 10 décembre
les 12 milliards d'annoncé et malgré le
grand débat et malgré la proximité d'un
débouché électoral même si les listes se
réclamant des filets jaunes obtiennent
des scores électoraux absolument marano
nos internautes sur ce sujet 60% d'entre
vous ne
sont choqués par l'existence de ce
fichage philippe no 10 de suite je suis
choqué le fichage est toujours un
problème car ou est la finalité on a
tenté de répondre et avec plus de points
d'interrogation finalement que de
réponses nicole je suis choqué les
médecins n'ont pas à faire un boulot de
délateurs babineau je suis également
choqué assez soulagé que les médecins se
mobilisent c'est inacceptable si chez
nous dit le fichage peut être utile tout
dépend qui s'en sert et pourquoi faire
citoyen payeur ce sont des consignes
données par l'intérieur aux hôpitaux
l'intérieur le ministère en aucun cas
une initiative médical et enfin babineau
nous dit place beauvau aurez accès la
place beauvau aurez accès à ce fichier
ce qui rend cette histoire encore plus
gênante en avant juste marque un mot
peut-être là-dessus mais je sais qu'on
aborde aussi donnez lui le tout avec la
présence de patrick peloux le dernier
sujet non mais aussi le un mot sur cette
histoire de la pitié d'intrusion et
l'attaquent
j'ai juste un mot non mais je suis
journaliste et pour moi le nombre de
personnes qui vont dans des urgences
après une manifestation comme toutes
celles qu'on a pu connaître avec les
violences qu'on a pu voir je pense que
c'est une information qui mérite d'être
connu de l'opinion publique les images
c'est une chose les faits les
statistiques ça donne une information
complémentaire et on excepte assez
normal qu on en répertorie je trouve que
c'est normal qu'on puisse être en
capacité de donner des informations
quand on voit les images qu'on voit ce
qu'ils permettent de les nuancer dans un
sens ou dans l'autre
d'accord c'est un arabe et ses dents
mais c'est un argument de journalistes
et de chercher la vérité est bien sûr
tout à fait respectable mais l'argument
médical c'est de dire qu'il ya le secret
médical qui est vraiment là que
l'enceinte le
le périmètre d'exercice de la médecine
et on ne peut pas déroger au secret
médical est donné c'est ce qu'on en fait
voilà c'est ce qu'on en fait et pour
nous l'important c'est ce qu'on en fait
ce but c'est ça va beaucoup plus loin
que ce que vous imaginez parce que il ya
des milliards de données sur votre santé
qui sont qui sont gérés le système de la
sécurité sociale et toutes les
informations qui remontent
vous avez des tas de multinationales
notamment dans le domaine pharmaceutique
qui voudraient ces données donc il y à
des véritables interpellations sur les
fichages il faut les protéger
moi ma seule question à chaque fois
conclus que j'ai des responsables des
services informatiques de l'assistance
publique-hôpitaux de paris où je
travaille qui sont là je leur dis vous
en est tous des systèmes de sécurité
et là il faut reconnaître qu'il met le
paquet sur la sécurité qui font des
exercices réguliers et c'est parce que
c'est vous pouvez pas imaginer lors que
c'est pour gégé national c'est c'est
très important et si nous pétrole de
demain
donc c'est exactement la forme et est
est ce que disait votre la réaction d'un
de vos internautes la cinu médecins on
ne tire pas la signer le signal d'alarmé
de temps en temps en disant attention là
on est en train de franchir même si on
n'a pas franchi une ligne rouge
on est en train de franchir une les
rouges et on s'en approche on peut pas
tout faire c'est pas parce que vous êtes
médecin que vous pouvez tout faire sur
les données des malades
un dernier mot rapide sur la sphère de
la pitié et 2
la taxe selon le ministre qui est revenu
sur ses propos ou non ce n'est pas une
attaque
en fait moi moi même audiard moi même au
départ
moi j'avais compris que c'était une
attaque ça a été présenté comme ça est
un peu sur le modèle qui avait il ya
quelques années au moment des
manifestations sur le sur la réforme du
travail où ils avaient caillassé necker
moi j'avais trouvé ça absolument
scandaleux donc ça a été au début
présenté comme ça en fait ce n'est pas
une attaque c'est un mouvement de foule
c'est une foule qui était devant la
pitié salpêtrière ils sont arrivés et il
ya eu une maniaque de l'appelant à la
lacrymo et ils sont rentrés ils ont vu
une porte une possibilité de s'échapper
par une porte ils sont montés septième
établissement d'intrusion et c'est
précis exacte et plus moi je pense que
c'est une suite d'une foule qui avait
peur
voilà je pense que c'est quelque chose
et c'est quelque chose comme ça il n'y a
eu aucune dégradation il n'y a eu aucune
violence à l'intérieur
bon c'est là où c'est là où il ya
peut-être un des termes de vocabulaire
qu'il faut choisir entre répression et
maintien de l'ordre
je pense que là le maintien de l'ordre
n'a pas été fait lui-même modelage c'est
comme sur les données le problème c'est
pas les fonds les mêmes
c'est l'interpellation par altération de
la manière dont on va pouvoir l'utiliser
à des fins politiques dans un débat
national
le problème il est là exactement on
s'arrête là si on veut parler et après
tu étais enfant qui a dit on a vraiment
peu de temps pardon alors vous le savez
ce retour des jets 10 depuis la chute de
death des chais fait toujours autant
polémique après les femmes les enfants
en général c'est aujourd'hui la question
du rapatriement des orphelins qui est en
jeu je vous le disais en titre cinq
enfants cinq orphelins âgés de moins de
cinq ans déjà été rapatriés et récemment
et d'autres devraient suivre c'est ce
que a dit hier la ministre des armées